ich beschäftige mich auch noch mit dem
thema corona ich habe nämlich die
debatte um die impfpflicht heute noch
mal mitgebracht die polarisiert
natürlich und ich finde man kann
politisch unterschiedlicher auffassung
sein man kann dafür sein man kann
dagegen seien aber was mich stört ist
dass wir jetzt von einigen teilen der
politischen landschaft erleben dass das
verfassungsrecht jetzt vorgeschoben wird
dass man sagt eine allgemeine
impfpflicht das geht
verfassungsrechtlich auf gar keinen fall
ich finde das ist etwas zu kurz
gesprungen denn das verfassungsrecht
kennt zu impfpflicht kein schwarz oder
weiß da gibt es auch grautöne und ich
finde wenn man denn diese impfpflicht
möchte da muss man auch über andere
alternativen reden die zum beispiel noch
nicht so in der diskussion waren zum
beispiel auch eine impfpflicht mit einer
art widerspruchslösung da gibt es eine
ganze reihe von themen wichtig ist aus
meiner sicht dass wir jetzt eine lösung
finden die auch die impfmuffel aktiviert
und wir müssen schauen wo all den
debatten impfpflicht ja das ist ein
wichtiges thema gerade rechtlich aber
ich sage auch es ist er etwas in
zukünftige wellen zu brechen ansonsten
müssen wir konsequent jetzt bei zwei
gegner haben wir das ist ja eine sehr
fach politische diskussion dann am ende
wenn es um verfassungsrecht geht darf
man das nutzen oder nicht ich finde
einfach ihre partei hat total versagt in
den vergangenen wochen ganz viele
ministerpräsidenten
fachpolitiker die uns monatelang erzählt
haben im bundestag jens spahn ich
garantiere ihnen eine impfpflicht wird
es nicht geben angela merkel hat das
gesagt markus söder hat das gesagt armin
laschet hat das gesagt was soll denn
noch irgendein mensch da draußen glauben
wenn sie das nächste mal irgendwo
hingehen und sagen zum beispiel die
sparer sind sicher das geld ist sicher
die renten sind sicher wären dass
das risiko so zu sagen da bei der
impfpflicht sich um 180 grad zu wenden
so hoch ist für die glaubwürdigkeit und
ich zweifel auch daran dass eine
impfpflicht momentan zumindest wirklich
hilft denn wenn wir sehen wie lange
schlangen sind in hamburg
münchen in berlin das wird ja noch nicht
mal organisiert bekommen diejenigen die
sich jetzt boostern lassen wollen oder
die erstimpfung machen wollen zu
versorgen was sollen wir denn dann mit
einem pflicht also ich mache mich jetzt
auch nicht zum hauptanwalt einer
impfpflicht ich glaube für manche ist es
richtig dass man dazu auch die meinung
geändert hat das haben einige auch
eingeräumt dass du einfach sagen sie das
ist eine garantie ist warum muss er das
immer ganz findet jeden ich finde
jedenfalls wichtig dass wir in dieser
debatte über die impfpflicht dann sagen
aus politischen gründen wollen wir es
nicht zum beispiel weil wir sagen es
hilft kurzfristig nicht da finde ich ist
die höflichen weil an der dann gegen
lächeln ist hört ja noch jemand einen
der wirklich sagt er ist dagegen setzt
bei der fdp kriegt man nicht mal so mit
oskar wobei ja aber nicht da ist
beispielsweise christian linder und
wolfgang kubicki für eine info vor
studenten so wolfgang kubicki wenn
definitiv nicht für eine impfpflicht sei
dann würde ich heute meine hand ins
feuer legen für ergo bickel da muss man
lange suchen bis man jemand bei der fdp
findet er sagt wir sind absolut dagegen
bald eine impfpflicht wird's geben ganz
klar vielleicht berufsgruppen aber für
immer mehr berufsgruppen allem übel gab
es auch einen allgemeine impfpflicht
dass sie kommen irgendwann wird sie
kommen natürlich wenn wir das nicht
anders brechen können wir haben immer
noch 30 millionen rund 30 millionen
deutsche die ungeimpft sind die muss man
irgendwie dahin
nicht alles ist wirklich bett news das
sind vier weniger als leute die keine
impfung haben das sollten auch immer
deutlich machen und wir werden
irgendwann dahin kommen dass die
schienen beschrieben für die wirtschaft
aber auch für die psyche der menschen
wenn man das nicht will muss man die
menschen impfen hier fallen noch zwei
positionen aufeinander dass eines der
kollege am tor der freie nach adenauer
sagt was schert mich das was ich gestern
gesagt habe
ich wollte ja nur als ich mir jetzt an
mit guten oder schlechten lohn ab wie
das das problem dass politik sich sehr
martialisch äußert und hat schon
garantieren dass in einer situation aus
der sie gar keine in der sie gar keine
erfahrung einen braun machen politik das
ist ja frage an herrn
ich würde es nicht machen weil die ganze
ab der korona pandemie hat gezeigt wie
zum teil
lächerlichkeiten angesammelt werden
mussten das begann ja mit den masken ich
war kurz vorher in dem ebola gebiet im
kongo
und wenn ich sehe was da alltäglich an
irgendwelchen seiten grenzübergängen für
sicherheitsvorkehrungen getroffen worden
wie säuberlich alles notiert wurde man
die temperatur wurde gemessen maske
niemand hätte so etwas diskutiert und
hier sagt der gesundheitsminister
brauchen wir aber das ist eine spannende
frage bela auch als ehemalige
regierungssprecher jetzt top top
kommunikationsexperte deutschlands
bilder wenn wir uns anschauen dass wir
journalisten erwarten immer klare
antworten politiker wollen klare
antworten geben
könnte ein politiker überhaupt sagen
beim thema impfpflicht im frühjahr zum
beispiel oder sommer ich weiß es nicht
vielleicht könnte es kommen vielleicht
auch nicht oder wird man so fest
gehämmert so gepresst als politiker dass
man sich da so klar in eine ecke drängen
natürlich muss man in der politik oder
als politiker als führender politiker
als minister als bundeskanzler
bundeskanzlerin klarheit geben auch da
in phasen wo möglicherweise noch offene
fragen sind das ist aber auch führung
und dann muss ich bereit sein dass
entweder durchzustehen auch
durchzufechten gegen widerstände oder
einzuräumen dass das falsch war was ich
angenommen aber beide möglichkeiten gibt
es ja auch nur wenn ich um ein anderes
beispiel sage ich sage bis zu
weihnachten können wir 30 millionen
menschen boost dann im november dann
muss sich auch sicherstellen dass das
wirklich sein kann bevor ich eine solche
meldung raus hemmer und wenn das nicht
das von der kanzlerin müssen wir nochmal
einen orden und bei der
ministerpräsident so ist das so und wenn
das nicht der fall ist dann fällt es auf
mich zurück und ist bringt diese unruhe
und diese psychische versehrtheit bei
den menschen die da in langen schlangen
stehen dann auf einmal weg geschickt
werden sich noch beschimpfen lassen
müssen wenn sie anfangen zu randalieren
und sagen leute wie sollten auch hierhin
kommen ihr habt keinen impfstoff mehr es
ist 18 12 wie bekommst 9 bis 18 uhr das
muss man einfach verstehen also wer
solche aussagen trifft in solchen aktion
in krisensituationen muss dafür sorgen
dass sie auch umsetzbar sind oder
umgesetzt werden das ist führung in der
krise das ist eigentlich kleines
einmaleins nicht mehr das große aber wie
hoch ist dem aus man muss ein thema
glaube ich in dieser kommunikation
impfpflicht ich habe mich das jetzt den
letzten tagen auch oft gefragt warum hat
man eigentlich solche absoluten aussagen
zum thema impfpflicht getroffen gerade
im zusammenhang mit corona weil wir
haben das in deutschland ja gehabt die
pocken im pflicht da gab's entscheidung
nie masern impfpflicht jetzt erst vor
kurzer zeit ein gefühl dann hat man sich
glaube ich mich gefragt wieso hat man zu
corona eigentlich so klare worte
gefunden glaubt das hat auch mit diesen
großen fake news zu tun gehabt die im
zusammenhang mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz im umlauf waren
ich meine ich erinnere mich an die
diskussion hunderte zuschriften von
bürgern design kommt jetzt mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz die zwangsimpfung
die afg andere haben sozusagen ein
verschwörungs mythen irgendwie auf
zwangsimpfung und ängste schüren gesetzt
und da haben wir gesagt nein so etwas
wie dort von populisten skizziert wird
so etwas wird nicht kommen und dabei
bleibt's ich jetzt auch niemand redet
darüber dass irgendwelche zwangsimpfung
kommen das ist auch gar nicht das thema
sondern jetzt gibt es ja eigentlich um
eine ganz andere frage nämlich um die
frage gibt es in irgendeiner form eine
rechtliche erwartung zum impfen und da
sage ich auch in der abwägung gerade in
der frage gesellschaftliche spaltung
finde ich auch mal müsste er und das ist
eigentlich auch der ansatz des punkts
heute er gucken wo sind lösungen
dazwischen wie kann man zb da den druck
erhöhen ohne jetzt sozusagen an den
ärger der fdp aber das argument in die
hand zu geben seht ihr wir haben es euch
schon immer gesagt jetzt kommen die da
mit der zwangsimpfung um die ecke da
muss man ganz klar gegen hatten deswegen
sage ich auch nicht schwarz oder weiß
sondern ein bisschen mehr licht in diese
debatte bringt wundern tut mich das
schon als ich klein war sieben oder acht
vielleicht erinnern sie sich auch noch
dran in der schule verstanden sagt im
funk pop im von kleidung vor der impfung
windpocken kinderlähmung kann dabei
würde ich ihnen alles in den armen hört
ja
auch nicht die ganze frage reichen daher
gebe es wir können auch nicht die ganze
verhandlung an den staat übergeben und
was sie mir gerade jetzt finde ich
furchtbar wenn in der schule da die
kinder die entfernt entstand mit ihren
eltern zum arzt zu gehen der staat ist
doch nicht für alles verantwortlich für
die gesundheit für die kinder für die
entziehung für alles dann haben wir
wirklich einen starken staat wir haben
jetzt schon zu einem starken start
zurück was mich sehr beängstigend wir
können noch also diese vorstellung dass
kinder in der schule einfach mal so hier
geht ist für mich furchtbar außerdem ist
eine recht die sagen wir schaffen das
gar nicht mehr diesen ansturm das geht
gar nicht mehr und du kannst jetzt
eltern natürlich musst du erklären ich
bin einverstanden oder nicht